all right let's debunk some nonsense
claims that are spreading always
important if you're going to engage with
this stuff to at least have some sense
of what reality is and understand where
the the talking points come from now one
of the things that I have said before is
that very often the completely incorrect
wild destructive uh conspiracy theories
um from the right have like a kernel of
Truth in their Origins now I don't mean
that the conspiracy theory itself has an
element of truth but what I mean is what
catalyzed the conspiracy theory is
something that is true that's like very
generally in the universe of what
they're talking about and we're going to
look at a clip here of uh Lara Logan
Lara Logan used to sort of be a
respectable journalist she has gone
completely off the rails we've covered
some of her anti-semitic stuff we've
covered all of her different conspiracy
theories she seems completely
disconnected from reality and she spoke
somewhere you know who the hell cares
it's another there's this circle the
speaking tour Circle where the crazier
you the crazier the things are that you
have to say the more likely it is that
you'll get more of these gigs and Lara
Logan claimed that illegal immigrants
who cross the border illegally get a
Social Security number at the border and
that then they can just go and vote now
none of that is true
I will tell you after we look at the
clip what is the likely origin of this
all right let's take a look question
they said they could not make a decision
at this time and they would let me know
um that's true but they asked me two
very interesting questions when I went
there they asked if I'd be willing to
take up arms to defend the constitution
of the
United isn't that interesting it seems
to have forgotten that part right
um and then uh you know among the many
uh interesting parts of this is as you
look around you and uh you know what you
have to remember is that they don't
actually believe in citizenship oh and
now when people come across the board
illegally I have this confirmed from
border patrol agents who are actually
physically doing this they get given a
social security number they get given
one
they get given that's interesting
and people in the crowd go right right
why would they get a Social Security
number that doesn't make any sense but
the crowd just right right they get
assigned a social security number when
they cross
I'm not sure how many of you are aware
of that and if you're ready well the
people aware of it are wrongly aware of
it because it's not true and we'll get
to that I don't know when the cheating
starts it's long before you polls right
right think about it it starts with the
census it starts with counting illegal
immigrants in the census how do you
determine uh how many members of
Congress you get population size right
so how does you know California has all
these delegates at the at the Electoral
College and now of course the reason
California has all those
um electoral votes is California's
population is genuinely massive it's
bigger than like most countries
um but also the larger your population
at least in some general sense the the
larger number of undocumented immigrants
that might also be there don't just get
more money from the federal government
for your increased population you don't
just get more congressional candidates
uh representing you what else do you get
you get an opportunity to pad the voter
rolls ah with people but wait Lara
undocumented immigrants can't vote
who are being completely and utterly
exploited and there's one thing that
I've that I've learned as I've been
investigating this is they love
euphemism right
they love euphemisms sort of like
Republicans right I mean they love to
say pro-life which really is a euphemism
for
uh we tell women what to do because it's
it's all about democracy and if there's
any form of voter security that's voted
suppression and racism and white
supremacy and if it's the other side you
know anything we can do to get more
people out to vote but actually when you
when you talk to the canvassers they'll
tell you that when they go into the
low-income areas
you know sometimes they're predominantly
Hispanic sometimes they're black
sometimes they're white but that's where
they find the most fraud fraud that all
the fraud is in those areas now it may
not Shock you that just about everything
she's saying is completely made up first
of all as far as fraud or the Freud or
fraud or whatever
um
it's really
it's almost non-existent and the couple
dozen cases that we've actually
identified since 2020 it's almost all
Republicans it's like white Republicans
in white Republican areas either testing
the system or like one guy voted for his
wife who disappeared we covered that
last week but most importantly the stuff
about
undocumented immigrants are getting
Social Security numbers at the border
which then allows them to vote Aaron
reichland Melnick explained the truth
about this on Twitter Aaron's the policy
director for the American Immigration
Council and used to be an immigration
lawyer some Asylum Seekers wrote he
wrote become eligible for a work
authorization while they wait now it
usually takes about a year it's not
happening at the border but there are
people who are in the U.S illegally
they've been in the U.S for a year
they've asked for Asylum they then get a
work authorization and they can get
what's called a restricted social
security number it's so that they can
pay taxes and legally work and listen to
this they pay into Social Security
they're not eligible to collect unless
they win Asylum and become citizens so
there are some undocumented immigrants
who after a year
while waiting for their Asylum request
to be adjudicated have asked for work
authorization have been told you can do
it but you've got to pay into Social
Security and if your Asylum request is
rejected and you get sent back to your
Source country you don't get anything
out of the social security system
essentially subsidizing the Social
Security payments of people who will
ultimately get benefits that's the truth
they're not eligible to vote they can't
register to vote they would not be able
to vote they don't vote they can't vote
so that's the kernel from which some of
these conspiracy theories originate
Asylum Seekers can sometimes
eventually get a restricted social
security number and that becomes at the
border you just show up and they give
you a social security number and next
thing you know you're voting for Biden a
complete and total farce does Lara Logan
know that she's lying
I think she probably does on this
particular one I think that she probably
does let me know what you think